california governor gavin newsom  i'm not saying he's the best i'm not  saying he's the most progressive i'm not  saying he's my favorite but he's coming  out and he is number one doing a really  good job of trolling right wingers which  we probably need to do to some degree  but number two  he understands where the left has failed  he gets that the left has to be ruthless  he gets that the left  can't equivocate  he gets how  destructive and low the right is willing  to go so he's a very skilled politician  california major surplus at this point  in time he could be a very strong  candidate if biden doesn't run for  re-election which i don't think he will